this is Alan Dean Foster hi I'm Alan
Dean Foster and he's a science fiction
writer yes I am he might even be
familiar with one of his books in 1975 I
worked with George Lucas and wrote the
book version of Star Wars no way yes way
this is Alan Dean Foster's office this
is the view from Alan Dean Foster's deck
this is how Alan Dean Foster met George
Lucas they were looking for someone to
do the book version of this science
fiction film that no one knew anything
about I was asked by my publisher if I'd
be interested I said yes and that's how
the book came to be it was the
opportunity of a lifetime but it came
with one pretty big caveat George's name
would be on the cover and I couldn't
admit to having ghostwritten the book so
he lied for a long time so I had to lie
to people's faces for 20 years this is
liar Alan Dean Foster's library he's
written a whole bunch of novelizations
Star Wars of course the first three
alien films The Chronicles of Riddick
Clash of the Titans and most recently
the force awakens and a lot of other
books too since the first these are
spells vanishing into the outer that's
maybe the least interesting thing about
them
there's secrets that will forever remain
unrevealed these are Alan Dean fosters
weightlifting trophies this is Alan Dean
Foster's benchpress okay here's Alan
Dean Foster's front kick got that from
Chuck Norris not a joke
here's Alan Dean Foster with his camera
he's recorded his travels on six
continents I'm stuck on this one planet
I'm determined to see as much of it as I
possibly can so how does a world-famous
crazy prolific sci-fi writer manage to
keep this up and still find time for his
writing well to stop learning is to
start to die didn't dysentery as arrest
me say that yes he did you know John
Ford only needed one take
[Music]